okay so I obviously I know Futurama uh
Hannah Montana obviously peep show you
guys talk about I feel like you've told
me about people sick on the British
shows then for now let's just go right
let's go to Taskmaster okay so people do
Peeps are then testamentally okay okay
so Peep Show yeah uh I will explain it
poorly you've explained it to me before
I remember better yeah
um so imagine two British people whose
life is just not going the way they
wanted right and instead of like
actually doing anything about it they
just take it out on each other and just
cause the most cringe situations for
everyone around them and themselves so
this isn't like this is like narrative
right like it's fiction or it's fiction
and it's but it's not like reality TV
right it is it is one of the most
intentionally cringe shows in existence
right yeah and if you love cringe humor
this is this is the king of it right
there's no show that even comes close to
this I mean I think the first episode
opens up uh with Jeremy who is one of
the two main characters of Jeremy and
Mark Marcus played by David Mitchell who
is a fantastic kind of he's really great
at playing these Weasley characters yeah
he's kind of like weasel looking
characters that are very like and he
plays that amazingly he plays this kind
of timid but very like selfish guy
penalized way smarter than he is kind of
like Michael Sierra like type or Michael
Sierra if I won't have to go wrong in
Michael's cereal Life to be
that bad it's like it's like imagine of
actually somewhat intelligent 40 year
old man who just made all the wrong life
decisions all right and is angry at the
world for it right and so he kind of
thinks that he's owed more than he gets
and so he just takes it out on everyone
else in a very British way right and he
just takes it out on Jeremy but Jeremy
is also just a giant buffoon yeah he's
an idiot right and the first episode
opens up I believe with
um Jeremy meets this girl who's wearing
like a beanie and he's like oh she's so
cute I want to have sex with her and
then I think they get together finds out
she has cancer and then doesn't want to
be with her and more and tries to kind
of break it off in a really weird way
and it's just so cringe where he's
trying to like he said because he
doesn't fully understand like he knows
what cancer is because he's never met
anyone with it he's just really [ __ ]
awful yeah being able to even remotely
understand how to talk to someone with
cancer yeah so he's just like he's like
when did this come out it's like 2 000.
okay so I was gonna say this very two
thousands humor yeah no no this is like
this this is easily air today
at all this is age like perfectly
because I still watch it to this day
right right me and Sydney still binge
all of the seasons unfortunately one of
the bad things about British televisions
unlike Americans
yeah yeah every like there's like seven
seasons of Peep Show but like every
season has six episodes
and that's six half an hour episodes as
well but like this is what I really love
about some British TV shows it really
feels like it earns the six episodes 30
minutes each where it's like there is
not a single beat missed in this show
yeah like there is no episode that sucks
yeah there's no episode that isn't funny
and there's no episode where there isn't
like five moments that isn't gonna make
you laugh out loud yeah right right just
like sometimes it's just every almost
every episode I think in Peep Show is an
absolute Banger and there are there are
some lines that are just like stuck with
me for like my entire life there's okay
there's a completely unrelated plot line
I feel like this sums it up so well yeah
uh there's a there's a there's an
episode where Jeremy is one of the
characters uh Works in a gym and Mark is
going to this gym and doesn't really
want to go to it but it's kind of being
forced to and Jeremy for some why does
Jeremy want to not go to the gym anymore
he does why does he not want to work
there I can't remember why
um
I think he joined it to get with a girl
or something like that yeah so he joins
the gym to get with this attractive uh
other worker there yeah and meanwhile
Mark doesn't want to go to the gym
anymore right so he makes up this
elaborate excuse that one of the
masseuses touched him yeah and it's like
it's this whole awkward ordeal where he
has to go to the office to the manager
yeah and awkwardly explain that he was
touched while the guy is there the
masseuse right it's just this stumbling
horrible cringe-inducing thing and and
he and he touched me and the guy what
the [ __ ] I didn't touch you and then to
get fired because Jeremy doesn't want to
work there anymore he like shits in the
pool and then tries to blame somebody
else it's this whole like it's just it
goes from zero to a hundred every single
episode where everything just
accumulates and and builds and it's just
fantastic it's so good yeah it's it's
cringe humor at its best it's British
humor at its best
um if you you want to feel like you're
British for some reason why I don't know
what you would watch this TV show tell
them to tell the British person you've
watched this show they'll love you
exactly I mean Sydney [ __ ] loves this
show that's you know and that's how I
knew that she could understand British
humor if you could get Peep Show because
I show Peep Show to my mum and dad
they're like why why it's too much for
my parents as well yeah it's too much
cringe it's a lot yeah there is not a
single episode where you won't be
uncomfortable yeah but the way the best
way I can describe it is like just
imagine two [ __ ] [ __ ] and try not
to be [ __ ] but in the end of the day
they're just they're just trying to get
on with life but they somehow find
themselves in the worst [ __ ]
situations right now it's so good and
like it's not just even these two
characters there's so many like
if you've lived in England you've like
recognized who these people are because
there's like some you know you know some
of these sometimes you have a show that
you it's a bit it's a bit too close to
home sometimes yeah because there are
some characters that you kind of
recognize as a person that you've met in
your life before in the UK yeah
um like one of one character that stands
out to me is like super hands oh my God
I think I think Super hands who's just
that guy who just brings drugs to
everything right and and he's just like
he's just lost control of his life right
right why is he called Superhead no one
knows no one knows this guy's just
insane and like there's you know it's
also shot really interestingly it's all
POV yeah I think that's why it's called
Peep Show yeah yeah because yeah and
they shoot the scenes multiple times but
like so the camera keeps swapping
between the povs so it's never a uh an
angle of like okay his over the shoulder
it's like it's always POV oh which makes
for some really good moments because a
lot of the times really really awkward
moments hit so hard because the person
who sees you that the awkward thing
happened looks directly at the camera
yeah and it's looking at it like you did
it yeah yeah it's really good it's so
good it's really interesting and it's
just amazing again it's it's I know the
TV show is kind of shot like this to my
knowledge
and it just works yeah oh that's
interesting yeah watch Peep Show it's
amazing I know I know you guys like rave
on about it yeah and the POV thing also
makes it feel very uncomfortable because
you're often in the face right there's a
lot and it feels like you're there you
kind of feel like okay this is cool yeah
and then obviously Taskmaster yeah which
I think is it's okay so task Mass let me
explain it before I get into it but I
think the show is is blowing up and it's
going to blow up a [ __ ] ton in the US as
well more I know a lot of people have
recently coming up to from the US like
have you heard a single Taskmaster I'm
like yeah yes it's very old in the UK
right uh it's I don't even know how you
explain this uh you get a bunch of
comedians together yeah I actually you
wanted to do a task master for after
dark yeah we definitely want to do this
at something yeah the format is just
gold yes so so basically such good it's
kind of like a game show but not really
and now that you've put Taskmaster on
I'm like [ __ ] I have so many shows I
should have put on my list that I
completely forgot there was this genre
so that that happens a lot yeah I wanted
to put up a panel or slash kind of
thingy type kind of yeah so I think this
is like a very British genre of TV show
which is why I completely forgot about
it where it's kind of like this British
panel slash game show right but the game
but the uh the uh but what you don't try
to do in this game show is Win basically
they just try to be as entertaining as
possible right so with task master it's
basically like a game show where you
take a bunch of comedians on and then
you give them the same task right it
could be anything right could range from
getting a marble out of a bottle that's
been sealed and like full of jelly or
some [ __ ] there's some really obscure
like things that you're like why would
you do this like yeah you know there'll
be like 30 shocks they'll be like find
the orange yeah the sock but all of them
will have something different and you're
allowed to like sniff three or touch two
right yeah so so yeah so they're given
like a very they're given a very
Ambiguously worded task right Sometimes
some tasks are more ambiguous than
others but it's up to the contestant to
figure out what is the best way to do
this task right and so there's always
like a life hack to solving it yeah yeah
there's there's not always a life so
it'll be just a house and you can do
anything in the house with the challenge
so like for one challenge it'll be like
they'll be in a room and they'll be like
hide three eggplants in the room okay
whoever hides their eggplants the
longest from the guy searching wins yeah
all right so it's like you know some
some contestants hide the eggplant
others Smash Up the eggplant and try to
like squish it into something yeah yeah
you know and some people start eating
whole eggplants yeah it's like there's
the rules are always set so ambiguous
where any interpretation is correct and
it's up to the Taskmaster to decide if
somebody deserves the point based on
yeah you know because maybe somebody did
something it's a little a little too
cheeky in the Taskmaster Yeah by Greg
Davis who's amazing we'll be like no I
don't like that yeah right that's why
it's like perfect for trash days because
we can't follow the rules
the rules are ambiguous and then you
never follow them and then the guy in
charge just changed his mind yeah yeah
so so that's that's that's the point
right I'm sure a lot of people be like I
can't believe he lost this task because
he didn't follow the rules correctly
well that's not really the point of task
master the point of task master is just
to see the funny ways that different
people can get creative different people
approach the same time right right oh
that sounds fun yeah yeah and and you
can go as out of the box as you want the
only important thing is you gotta it's
kind of like you kind of you kind of
gotta like try to not to take the piss
but also take the piss as well right so
I remember what like one one task I
remember recently was there was this
switch in this room and the task was
figure out what this switch does right
yeah and so what happens is like nine
people out of ten they start they start
flipping on the switch running out
looking at every light in the house
looking at every Appliance in the house
seeing if anything's changed run back in
and like flip the switch off and then
they they repeat this process right
until they finally figure out that the
switch Rotator statue or something
that's that's what the switch did yeah
one guy just cut the power to the switch
right and was just like oh switch does
nothing
because it has no power
oh wow so that's that's the kind of like
thinking outside the box because it
didn't necessarily because he's
technically right yeah in that this
twitch does nothing in that moment
because he's seriously not breaking the
rules because there's no rules right
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's very
loose rules yeah that's very very loose
one of the best things is is that it's
completely available on YouTube for free
yep you can watch all of it nearly all
of it on YouTube for free yeah uh which
is amazing because the clips they have
Eclipse Channel which is amazing but you
can just watch the straight up the whole
episodes oh cool and the best part is is
that it's it's structured in a way where
every episode is its own self-contained
thing right uh in like a greater season
so it'll be the same comedians for the
whole season and the points will rack up
but you could come into any episode and
enjoy an episode like there is nothing
that requires you to watch the previous
episode right right if you want to and
you'll get more out of it you can go one
two three four up until the end then you
can see who the winner is yeah yeah so
it's Seasons they have like five
Comedians and they change kind of it
makes it a bit more consistent and makes
it have a lot more re-watchability and
more reasons to tune in every week it's
really good really really good yeah it's
going to blow up in the year I highly
recommend it we'll probably do do a task
Market I think a lot I know it's already
popular nice because they made a US
version that sucked as they always do of
course but I think a lot more YouTubers
and stuff will probably start doing some
stuff like that oh yeah it's gonna
happen yeah